every now and then we like to do a
little segment we call simon says that's
when you send in questions and i try to
answer them this is that segment so here
we go
what is the difference between
complaining versus feedback both giving
and receiving
i think complaining is when it's about
you feedback is when it's about them
when you actually care about how someone
else is doing it's feedback complaining
is when you're worried about how it
affected you it's whiny and it doesn't
really help people can't hear
complaining but if it's delivered in an
effective way they can absolutely hear
feedback so i think one is about you and
one is about them and feedback should be
given with love
okay next question
what if i feel like it's too late to
decide what i want to do with my life
it's never too late to decide what you
want to do with your life
better late than never right
at the end of the day we all want to
find something that we're passionate
about we want to do something that we
believe in that we feel connected to
some people are lucky that they figured
out 20 30 40 50 60 who cares when you do
it it's kind of like moving house i used
to live in one neighborhood in new york
city and i fell in love and i moved to a
different neighborhood and i thought oh
this new neighborhood is so much better
and i lived for 10 years in that other
neighborhood within a few months i felt
like this was my neighborhood and it was
great and i've always been doing it
it's kind of like that you know which is
if you find the thing you love
you'll be so consumed and in love with
it it doesn't matter when you do it as
long as you're doing it so definitely
definitely if you don't think you're
doing something you love
definitely look for it no matter how old
you are you'll find it unbelievably
rewarding i promise
what do you do when you feel overwhelmed
so i get overwhelmed when i have too
much stuff on my plate there's just too
many things going through my head and i
just can't keep up and i sort of do a
little bit of this and a little bit of
that and it drives me nuts so the
easiest way to beat that is to organize
a little bit in other words i make a
list of all the things that i have to do
in priority order and that's really
important because i start with number
one and i get through the whole thing so
i can cross it out before i go to number
two so if i'm unable to get through
everything in the day or the week or
whatever the time frame is at least i
got the most important things done do
you have any advice or guidance for
people who are trying to start their own
business yes absolutely this was really
the core of start with why i had a
business that was struggling and when i
learned to start with why it profoundly
changed the course of my business
understanding your why why you started
this business in the first place is
absolutely essential it's much easier to
get a job and get steady pay and get
benefits it's way safer what is so
important that you're willing to risk
the overwhelming chance of failure to do
this thing it has to really matter
beyond simply making money having
freedom or being your own boss those
things are not enough to sustain year
after year after year of some of the
most difficult stress and difficult
things that you will ever do
know your why you'll go back to it
constantly and it'll help you fill the
business it'll help you hire people who
believe what you believe which
ultimately makes for a great team
okay
covet is ending in some places um but it
feels like my work life isn't changing
at all how can i avoid burnout as things
open back up but i still feel stuck
behind a computer screen you know this
burnout thing is proving to be a bigger
problem than any of us expected i think
one of the great things that came out of
covet is we all recognize that time
and family and friends and sometimes our
own energy in our own lives is really
important i mean intellectually we've
always known that but we didn't stop
working and so i'm starting to see
people making hard decisions
they're taking jobs that pay them less
money but give them more time for
themselves
forward-thinking companies are also
recognizing that burnout is a thing and
they're offering people an extra day off
or
closing the office early or closing the
whole company down for two or three days
to just let people reset their batteries
i think the most important thing that we
can do when we're starting to feel
burnout is to believe it or not worry
about the people we work with who are
burning out as well
when we are in service to others who are
struggling with the thing that we're
struggling with we are more likely to
solve our own problems as well so if
you're burning out odds are high that
somebody close to you is also burning
out commit to helping them and i
guarantee you you'll help yourself
do you have any advice for networking
with other professionals well networking
is something that i always found
uncomfortable i'm naturally
an introvert and so when i go to
networking events i have to like drink
tons of coffee so that i'll have energy
and at the end i'm absolutely exhausted
and
i used to come across as way too eager
because i guess i was jacked up on
coffee and so the best advice i can have
for networking honestly is knowing why
you do what you do this is the only
thing that changed when my career
profoundly changed which is i stopped
talking about what i did and i started
talking about what i believed so for
example prior to my why if i went to a
networking event and somebody said that
dreaded question what do you do i would
say i run a small marketing consultancy
where we help big brands articulate
their value to the i mean
boring right
and then after i learned my why people
would say to me what do you do and i
said i teach leaders and organizations
how to inspire people
if they believed what i believed they
heard the word inspire and they said
cool tell me more about that and we were
talking about my stuff for the next 20
minutes if they didn't believe what i
believe they said what kind of companies
and i knew it was going to be a short
conversation so not only did it make my
work more compelling but it also helped
me filter who are more likely to be
better connections than others learn to
start with why and learn to have a pitch
that starts with why it makes a profound
difference
i'm trying to stay true to an infinite
mindset but i also feel like i'm not
moving fast enough toward my goals how
can i reconcile an infinite mindset with
the pressures of becoming successful how
do you define success
are you only defining success by the
money you make the promotions you get in
which case you're sliding back into that
finite mindset this takes practice
remember finite and infinite are not
mutually exclusive you can absolutely
have ambition you can act absolutely
want to do well but trying to fix those
things on a fixed time frame like i'm
going to be a millionaire by the time
i'm 30 i'm going to sell my business and
have an ipo by the time i'm 35 and when
you get a promotion by next year those
things are not entirely in your control
and so to put artificial goals like that
is fine but they have to be guide points
rather than goals so i do stuff like
that as well but i see them as guide
points sometimes i'm early sometimes i
hit the date and sometimes i'm slow the
point is you want to focus on the
momentum are you moving towards the goal
and uh you know
also think about uh some infinite
ambitions as well that that you may
never see
uh come true in your life i have a
vision i want to see a world which
people feel inspired safe and fulfilled
i know i will not live to see that world
happen and what matters to me is that
there's enough momentum that i will lie
on my deathbed and say it'll go on
without me that's how we have an
infinite mindset
what do i do if half of my team wants to
come back to the office and half of my
team wants to continue working from home
that is a hard question that a lot of
people are grappling with right now the
reality is we can't force anybody to do
what they don't want to do and we will
have mass rebellion if we attempt to you
can't say we're all staying at home when
some people want to come in and we can't
say everybody has to come in when some
people want to stay home and so it's
about finding a right balance and
letting people know that they will have
to make a little compromise now and then
for each other so some people who want
to stay away will have to come in every
now and then for meetings and to just be
a part of the culture and for people who
only want to come in they have to get
comfortable with sometimes some people
want to stay away it's a compromise it's
called teamwork and we have different
personalities we also have to remember
the benefits remember
the office generally
is supportive of an extrovert mentality
so coming in being friendly being social
where some people they need to just like
hide away and do their work and they'll
actually be more productive so
understanding a blended model we're
actually going to help people work to
their natural strengths talk about that
with your team both the compromise part
but also helping people work to their
natural strengths and we can try and
find something that works for everyone
okay um i have a great idea but i just
can't seem to find the motivation or
confidence to get started on it do you
have any advice for breaking through
that final barrier absolutely tell
people about your idea tell people about
your idea the more you talk to your
friends or even other people about your
idea you'll get feedback whether they
think it's a good idea too
my friend charlie said that if two
people think something is a good idea
then it's a good idea so we don't know
it's a good idea until other people
react to it and if they react positively
they'll either encourage you check in on
you put a little peer pressure on you
which sometimes helps or sometimes
they'll say that's amazing i'll do it
with you i struggle to self-motivate i
need a team i need somebody with me so
if i have at least one person who says i
will do that with you i'm fantastic i
will show up for them but i'm like you
left my own devices sometimes i can get
down on myself find someone who believes
in your idea those are all the questions
i have for today please send more and
we'll do another segment soon until then
take care of yourself and take care of
each other
[Music]